[Music]
no this is not a video about the
fictional 70s blockbuster jaws we're
talking about a fish that's much much
smaller than a great white shark but
that's gonna bite about two times
greater supposedly its teeth are so
sharp that if it were to bite you you
would only realize it after you saw
blood but what if you were attacked by a
school of these colorful fast-moving
carnivores how much would you feel and
how long would you last this is what if
and here's what would happen if you fell
into a pool full of piranhas piranhas
have been around for a really long time
fossil evidence puts the piranhas
ancestors in South America as far back
as 25 million years ago and the modern
piranhas we know and love today have
been here for 1.8 million years so we've
had some time to learn about these
fearsome little river dwellers but how
much of it is true pay attention what
you're about to see might just save your
life that piranhas are vicious
bloodthirsty creatures that will tear
you apart in minutes is largely a myth
in 1914 former US President Theodore
Roosevelt was on a survey expedition in
Brazil where he witnessed a group of
locals tossing a dead cow into a river
that they had stocked with starving
piranhas the feeding frenzy that
followed led Roosevelt to see piranhas
as the embodiment of evil ferocity he
compared their teeth and their jaws to
those of sharks and claims that their
preferred prey is usually much larger
than themselves
well the story stuck and naturally like
jaws before it piranhas became a 1978
cult classic spreading several myths
about
fish that a lot of people still believe
the real truth is that piranhas are
relatively calm fish and most of them
are scavengers that feed on insects
worms and plant material in the rivers
where they live of the few species of
piranhas that are attracted to the smell
of blood well they tend to go for prey
that's roughly the same size as them in
fact if you fell into a pool of piranhas
chances are they'd actually be scared of
you piranhas aren't really interested in
humans unless they are extremely hungry
and the human is already dead but it's
not like someone would starve a pack of
piranhas and put them in a pool just to
watch them eat something at worst you
might get nipped and not on a little
which is scary enough but you can rest
assured that there has never been a
scientifically proven case of a human
being killed by a piranha
sorry gory b-movie lover but don't let
me spoil all of fun even though you know
the truth now the idea of what piranhas
can do is still terrifying these fish
typically grow up to 50 centimetres long
they hunt in packs and have a bite force
that's three times their body weight
this means that relative to its size a
piranha bites harder than a great white
shark harder than an American alligator
harder than a t-rex and even harder than
a Megalodon and while it's highly
unlikely to happen if for some reason
you were attacked by a school of
piranhas roughly 400 of them could turn
you into a skeleton in about five
minutes but of course there's always a
bigger fish so even if piranhas aren't
something you have to worry about
there's still a lot of underwater that
you'll want to avoid can you imagine
being swallowed whole by a whale well
that's a story for another what if